what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and there has been a lot
of talk about the fantastic four
recently mostly due to the director that
they had lined up to direct the
fantastic four in the mcu john watts he
has stepped out he is no longer going to
be the director for the fantastic four
now keep in mind he just got done
directing spider-man no way home for
marvel studios and sony pictures so he
had already been with marvel and he had
already signed up for the fantastic four
sadly that is no longer the case however
it looks like we might have some good
updates about the fantastic four movie
about the director and about some of the
cast because remember this movie might
actually be a lot further along than you
think it is kevin feige announced the
fantastic four were coming all the way
back in sdcc in 2019 plus not to mention
kevin feige announced over a year ago
that the fantastic four movie was in
development so in this video we'll talk
about all that we know right now about
the fantastic four coming to the mcu and
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news alright so to
start off let's talk about how this is
not a bad thing for marvel studios or
the fantastic four movie i've heard a
lot of different rumors out there some
saying that the movie could be in
trouble that they've already cast people
but they're recasting now that john
watts left because the script sucks none
of this is true deadline is the one that
originally reported this and they have
actual comments from marvel studios and
all of it is good according to
deadline.com and the exclusive article
that they posted about this jon wants to
step in a way simply because he needs a
break rightfully so spiderman no way
home was a massive movie that they had
to keep secret for a very long time and
he's been working non-stop for a while
too so it's understandable that he would
want to take a break after one of the
biggest movies of all time the article
literally says nothing sinister here
watts just needs a break from the
superhero realm after completing the
spidey trilogy with tom holland and
zendaya keep that in mind he didn't just
direct spider-man no way home but he
directed the entire trilogy homecoming
far from home and no way home and here's
what marvel studios is president kevin
feige and marvel studios co-president
louis de esposito said collaborating
with jon on the spider-man films has
been a true pleasure we were looking
forward to continuing our work with him
to bring the fantastic four into the mcu
but understand and are supportive of his
reasons for stepping away we are
optimistic that we will have the
opportunity to work together again at
some point down the road and here's what
watts said making three spider-man films
was an incredible and life-changing
experience for me i'm eternally grateful
to have been a part of the marvel
cinematic universe for seven years i'm
hopeful we'll work together again and i
can't wait to see the amazing vision for
fantastic four brought to life so main
thing to take away here nothing to worry
about for the fantastic four john watts
is not leaving because the movie sucked
or because they're changing actors or
the script is bad in fact john watts
said in this deadline article that the
vision for the fantastic four movie
coming to the mcu is amazing and let's
be honest this project the fantastic
four is huge it is massive why because
it is going to be the first project
where marvel studios actually uses fox
characters with the exception of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but it kind of doesn't count obviously
because they aren't main mcu characters
and the story isn't based off of the
illuminati although it was quite
arguably the best part of the movie but
this is the first full project that is
solely focusing on fox characters and
its marvel's first family so best be
assured that marvel studios is going to
do everything they can to make this
movie fantastic pun intended and that's
going to start with a new director and
it looks like we have some pretty
interesting news here that's come out in
the last couple of days now there are
two pieces of information here that have
been going around and they're not
confirmed in any way nothing's confirmed
until the studio announces it but i do
like our two choices for directors right
now one is going to be john krasinski
now fans have been wanting john
krasinski to play mr fantastic for years
now there is just a ton of fan art out
there of john krasinski as mr fantastic
and we know that he would do an amazing
job however rumors right now are that he
is in talks with marvel studios to
direct the fantastic four now keep in
mind this does not mean that he won't be
acting in it as well but recently jon
has been picking up the director's role
it's something that he's enjoyed doing
and has been doing recently of course i
think a lot of people know he directed a
quiet place and a quiet place part two
however recently a bit of new
information has come out about another
person that could also be directing and
playing a role of the fantastic four of
sue storm and that is bryce dallas
howard current rumblings right now state
that bryce dallas howard is close to
signing on to direct and right the
fantastic four and may end up starring
in it as well potentially as the
invisible woman slash sue storm but also
she could be playing a love interest of
the thing this rumor also states that
krazynski will be signing on to play mr
fantastic and he's set to executive
produce and write now of course these
are just rumors but keep in mind that
krasinski has confirmed that he has
spoken to marvel studios this of course
is confirmed and bryce dallas howard has
already directed for disney she directed
two great episodes of the mandalorian
chapter 4 and chapter 11 and she
directed the book of boba fett series
chapter 5 the return of the mandalorian
quite possibly the best episode of that
series so far at least one of the better
episodes so she's already tight with
disney and she's already directed for
them so there could be a lot of truth to
this and it looks like marvel might be
close to honing in on who they want to
direct the fantastic four film they're
gonna jump on this really quick so it
makes sense that rumblings would already
be starting to go around they've been
working on this already for a year
they've really been working on it longer
than that but actually sitting down in
the studio in the board room coming up
with the ideas putting the story
together for a year so we could be
looking at right here mr fantastic slash
reed richards and sue storm slash the
invisible woman with bryce dallas howard
playing sue storm and john krasinski
playing mr fantastic and i wanna know do
you like this casting if this ends up
being the casting for these two i think
i've heard enough over the past two
years to know that people really like
the idea of john kuczynski playing mr
fantastic but do you like bryce dallas
howard playing sue storm and this of
course makes you think these rumors are
true have they already cast the actors
they want to play the human torch and
the thing i still personally think that
zac efron would make a pretty good human
torch and as far as the thing is
concerned i'm assuming most of it's
going to be prosthetics or cgi so you
don't really need a huge beefy person
really you just need a good actor i've
obviously heard a lot of the rock's name
being thrown out there but this worries
some people but let me know who you
would pick to play the human torch and
the thing and also spoiler warning right
now if you have not seen doctor strange
in the multiverse madness i am about to
briefly talk about it three two one
let's go okay obviously john krasinski
played mr fantastic in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness i didn't want
to come out and say that for the people
who haven't seen it yet i wanted them to
enjoy this video but obviously he's
already played mr fantastic it's not
going to be that much for him to simply
return and play mr fantastic as well if
i had to guess i'm assuming he is going
to be our mr fantastic the only other
guess at this point right now is whether
or not he is going to direct or write or
produce or simply do everything as we've
seen recently he can pretty much do it
all thanks for sticking with me till the
end so we didn't have to spoil that for
everybody who hasn't seen the movie but
go ahead and leave your thoughts about
these casting choices and director
choice down below who would you like to
see play marvel's first family let me
know don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu videos for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof